[Música]
volvemos por supuesto a hablar de
economía en directo américa de france24
daniela blandón vamos a hablar de la
gasolina en eeuu que está en su menor
precio en 5 meses es una buena noticia
para los usuarios de los carros hoy
también motos y bueno todo lo que lleve
gasolina para andar claro que si raúl es
que mire yo cuando vio en eeuu hace seis
años el galón de gasolina ha costado un
dólar consiga el dólar 50 del dólar 50
más o menos 4 en junio pasado ese precio
subió a más de 5 dólares cuando hace un
año también pasaba apenas los dos
dólares en promedio en todo el país con
este dato comenzamos entonces porque
sumado a los altísimos precios de los
alimentos y los precios de los
combustibles dispararon la inflación
nada más del 9 por ciento en el sexto
mes del año pero el miércoles este
precio del galón de combustible cayó a
399 dólares por galón este es un nivel
no visto desde marzo de este año según
la asociación estadounidense de
automóviles que hace un seguimiento muy
juicioso diariamente de este y eso se
debe a que en parte a que los precios
del petróleo que al comienzo de la
guerra de ucrania casi se ubicaron sobre
los 140 dólares por barril ahora estén
en un poco más de 90 dólares en julio
entonces esos precios de los
combustibles cayeron casi un 8% frente
al mes anterior sin embargo si lo
comparamos frente a julio del año pasado
si son 44 por ciento más altos la mayor
caída la experimentó el estado de ohio
con 136 dólares por galón y la menor
caída estuvo en hawai con 21 centavos
por galón caídas caída igual así es ante
todo esto dani le pregunto si puede
haber tranquilidad en torno a los
precios del consumidor con esta
volatilidad de los precios de la
gasolina es la pregunta que se está
haciendo todo el mercado en este momento
para la cual pues no hay una respuesta
certera lo que sí coinciden muchos
analistas es en que ya pasó lo peor o
pudo haber pasado y la inflación en eeuu
tocó un pico que ya comienza a descender
como lo explica una de ellas
el índice de precios al consumidor es
una canasta de diferentes artículos y
nos da una idea de cómo están cambiando
los precios si están subiendo o bajando
es muy importante porque en eeuu dos
tercios de nuestra economía se basan en
el gasto del consumidor y si el ipc sube
demasiado y es demasiado alto entonces a
los consumidores les resultará difícil
comprar más bienes y esto ralentizará
las compras y por lo tanto hará lo mismo
con la economía entonces ver hoy que los
números bajaron a 8,5 por ciento desde
más de 9% es un movimiento positivo y es
de
lo que se preguntan entonces es seguirán
subiendo las tasas o van a bajar pues
algunas de las cabezas de las reservas
federales locales ya advirtieron que
falta mucho camino para que la inflación
esté en un nivel que les permita frenar
esa política de aumento de tasas de
interés y le voy a dar un pequeño dato
el banco espera que la inflación en un
estado saludable será del 2% y está en
el 8,5 por ciento así que todavía falta
está bien bien lejos de ese 2% de annie
le pregunta entonces cómo recibir en los
mercados estos datos de inflación vamos
con los indicadores claro pues el
miércoles hubo fiesta en wall street le
cuento porque los principales índices
subieron hasta un 3 por ciento en el
caso del tecnológico nasdaq por este
dato de inflación y hoy abrieron también
al alza y estas noticias de que la
inflación se está desacelerando causaron
furor y le voy a decir por qué porque el
mercado entonces está esperando que
posiblemente la reserva federal frene un
poquito esa política tan agresiva que ha
llevado durante los últimos meses y no
siga subiendo las tasas de interés el
cobre por ejemplo está en máximos de
seis semanas y en asia hong kong tuvo
ganancias del 2% y si nos vamos a europa
en donde también los índices están al
alza la noticia viene de ucrania y a
usted le va a gustar
mcdonald se comenzará a reabrir algunos
de sus restaurantes en este país en los
próximos meses como una muestra de apoyo
después de que la cadena estadounidense
se retirara de rusia esta cadena también
había cerrado temporalmente en ucrania
pero si le siguió pagando sus más de
10.000 empleados en kiev haya han
reabierto otros negocios occidentales
como nike kfc o incluso el minorista
español mango a ver si nos desayunamos
un hash browns de mcdonald's un muffin
rico que
en argentina anuncian un aumento del
monto de la pensión dan y bueno se
estaba desarrollando el miércoles una
nueva protesta en la que los
manifestantes pedían una reunión con el
nuevo ministro de economía sergio massa
a en ese mismo momento de la anunciaba
un aumento del 15 53 por ciento en las
pensiones efectivo a partir de
septiembre y que según él alcanzará a
más de 16 millones de ciudadanos de esta
manera la pensión mínima entonces pasa
de un poco más de 43 mil pesos
argentinos o 311 dólares a precios de
hoy a 50 mil 353 pesos que son 360
dólares quienes reciban este monto que
es el mínimo también van a tener un bono
equivalente a 50 dólares de hoy para
hacer frente a la inflación y es que el
aumento de las jubilaciones por ley en
este país ocurre cada tres meses y la
atención entre china y eeuu volvió al
terreno comercial claro porque esta
semana el presidente de estados unidos
joe biden firmó un proyecto de ley con
el que busca promocionar la cola
la fabricación de microchips les va a
dar 52 mil 700 millones de dólares en
subsidios pues estos microchips han
estado bastante escasos desde el segundo
año de la pandemia y a china no le está
gustando esta idea de que eeuu produzca
más ya que taiwán que considera parte de
su territorio es el mayor productor del
mundo este proyecto de ley afirma
mejorar la competitividad de la
industria tecnológica y de chips de eeuu
pero en realidad proporciona enormes
subsidios a sus empresas nacionales de
fabricación de chips y promueve
políticas de apoyo discriminatorias y
diferenciadas incluidos algunos términos
que restringen la inversión en las
actividades económicas y comerciales de
las empresas interrumpirá el comercio
internacional y distorsionar a las
cadenas mundiales de suministro de
semiconductores china se opone
firmemente a eso ahora sí pague la deuda
daniele la cifra el día cómo le va con
las de plataformas de streaming me
encantan las plataformas destruyen las
uso mucho bueno pues le voy a dar una
noticia y es que
221 como 1 millones de suscriptores
acumula en sus plataformas de streaming
el gigante de entretenimiento walt
disney company esta cifra incluye disney
pas julio y la de deportiva y speed en
más entre todas ellas están sumando
abonados que los
220 más abonados de los 220 6 millones
de netflix y es que disney también
anunció que aumentará en 38% los precios
para los clientes que quieran ver sus
películas sin comerciales en eeuu el
valor será de 10 99 dólares mensuales lo
que están haciendo tratando de hacer
como un modelo claro que por más que
pagues suscripción igual vas a ver
anuncios y si no los quieres ver pagan
más pagas más dan y como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica nos vemos mañana
con más economía y pasamos a saludar a
luis méndez que nos tiene toda la
información deportiva